un tronco con forma de cilindro tiene un
diámetro de 2 pulgadas y este va a ser
una información importante se corta una
porción del tronco al hacer dos cortes
planos que atraviesan completamente el
tronco el primero es perpendicular al
eje del cilindro y el plano del segundo
forma un ángulo de 45 grados con el
plano del del primer corte la
intersección de los dos cortes tiene
exactamente un punto el número de
pulgadas cúbicas en la porción del
tronco puede expresarse como n pi donde
n es un entero positivo encuentra el
valor de n entonces primero que nada
para tratar de resolver este problema
hay que dibujar de qué estamos hablando
entonces tenemos un tronco con forma de
cilindro y que tiene un diámetro de 12
pulgadas entonces vamos a dibujar
nuestro tronco
aquí está la base de nuestro tronco muy
bien
y este tronco se extiende en esta
dirección porque es un cilindro
este es un cilindro y es nuestro tronco
muy bien ahí tienen ustedes este tronco
y nos dice además que vamos a cortar una
porción del tronco al hacer dos cortes
planos que atraviesan completamente el
tronco muy bien dice el primero es
perpendicular al eje del cilindro
entonces si aquí tienen el eje digamos
es digamos es esta línea que va por todo
el centro del cilindro tenemos que
cortarlo de forma perpendicular verdad
si tenemos aquí el eje ahí está digamos
el eje entonces nosotros cortamos de
esta forma de tal suerte que aquí en la
intersección hay un ángulo de 90 grados
entonces lo que tenemos es simplemente
cortar y tenemos justo este tipo de
cortes justo un corte transversal verdad
ahí tienen ustedes el corte transversal
a lo largo de éste más bien bueno que
justamente estamos cortando este este
cilindro nuestro tronco verdad
y eso fue hacer el primero de ellos
verdad el primero es el primero es
perpendicular al eje del cilindro y el
plano del segundo forma un ángulo de 45
grados con el con el plano del primer
corte entonces digamos tenemos aquí aquí
vamos a hacer el corte y más o menos
vamos a hacer
un corte de este estilo que por supuesto
aquí ya digamos el corte no se ve
circular sino más bien es como elíptico
muy bien y ahí tienen ustedes su corte
muy bien cuál es la luz lo importante
que se forma un ángulo de 45 grados aquí
muy bien 45 grados y este fue nuestro
segundo corte y esta es la porción que
estamos obteniendo del tronco muy bien
dice la intersección de los dos tiene
exactamente un punto que es este que
estoy marcando aquí y el número de
pulgadas cúbicas en la porción de este
tronco estamos pensando en esta porción
delimitada por estos dos dos cortes
puede expresarse como n pi donde en es
un entero positivo hay que hallar quien
es n muy bien entonces déjenme hacer
este mismo dibujo recrearlo de este lado
digamos está esta cara de aquí o esta
base de la porción la voy a poner acá
ahí está
más o menos
más o menos o que quizás debería
repetirlo un poco
y ésta
esa es nuestra base digamos de la
porción
que en perspectiva pues parece elíptico
verdad aunque ese si es ese si es
circular muy bien entonces tenemos
nuestra base y después recreamos este
corte esencialmente lo que hay que
dibujar es esta altura esta altura
ahí está la altura y a partir de aquí
con este punto vamos a conectarlos
y conectarlos más o menos así
no es así muy bien quedó muy bien el
dibujo y entonces solo para para darle
bien la profundidad vamos a hacerle
digamos como si fuera esto punteado
verdad que se ve por atrás
ahí lo tienen entonces este es nuestro
pedazo que obtenemos y la hipótesis
fundamental es que aquí en este punto
donde se hace el corte digamos si
tenemos si tuviéramos este este diámetro
y voy a pintarlo así bueno esta esta
línea aquí justo esta línea con la base
se hace un ángulo de 45 grados muy bien
y ahí lo tienen entonces la la primera
vez que yo vi el problema pensé no usar
cálculo verdad tenemos que calcular un
volumen pues hay que a lo mejor
encontrar algo que rota o que se yo pero
en realidad y este tipo de problemas
están diseñados para que no tengas que
hacer cuentas tan tan espeluznantes sino
simplemente tienes que tener una idea
muy buena y un truco que te ayude a
resolverlo de forma fácil y en realidad
este es uno de esos ejercicios porque
tiene una idea muy muy muy sencilla y si
y cuando te des cuenta vas a ver que es
muy
muy fácil de entender y el truco es
considerar no sólo esto sino considerar
otra porción encima ok
bueno quizás eso está muy chueco
pero si consideramos otra porción aquí
encima aquí
si nosotros consideramos otra porción
que es lo que hemos obtenido muy bien y
por supuesto esto también
es exactamente la misma porción pero
encima de la que ya teníamos esto
correspondería a haber hecho un corte
aquí
tener un corte aquí
verdad y ahora considerarnos todo esto
completito y lo que obtuvimos es
justamente un cilindro un cilindro
completito entonces es más fácil
calcular el volumen de este cilindro y
después tendremos que dividir entre dos
verdad porque son dos pedacitos iguales
entonces sólo nos interesa uno y de
hecho sabemos que este cilindro tiene
esta base que es circular y esto mide
dos de verdad porque es exactamente
igual que el de abajo y sabemos que el
cilindro tiene un diámetro de 12
pulgadas muy bien entonces con esta
información ya podemos empezar a
calcular todo lo que necesitamos porque
para saber el volumen de un cilindro
necesitamos el área de la base por la
altura entonces si ésta es nuestra
altura nos falta encontrar quien es la
altura y el y aquí es en donde entra
fuertemente que estamos trabajando con
un trío con un perdón con un cilindro
donde hacemos el corte de 45° porque
fíjate muy bien en este triángulo que
voy
es esta diagonal que atraviesa la
porción y luego nos vamos con esta
altura
y luego conectamos estos dos puntos muy
bien entonces aquí tenemos un triángulo
rectángulo un triángulo rectángulo pero
que además este ángulo es de 45 grados
déjamelo dibujo por ejemplo aquí más
bonito aquí tenemos nuestro triángulo
que acabo de trazar este ángulo es de 90
grados este es de 45 grados y a éste le
resta hacer también un ángulo de 45
grados muy bien entonces qué es lo que
tenemos este esta altura es h que es lo
que queremos encontrar no sabemos cuánto
mide esta hipotenusa o esta diagonal
pero lo que sí sabemos es cuánto mide
este diámetro verdad y eso mide 12
entonces si nos damos cuenta este lado
es igual a este lado porque es un
triángulo isósceles entonces lo que
podemos concluir de aquí es que nuestra
altura es justamente h h es exactamente
12 muy bien y con la altura ya podemos
calcular el volumen de todo este
cilindro cuánto
y cuánto es bueno sabemos que el volumen
de un cilindro es igual al área de la
base por la altura cuánto cuánto mide
bueno cuánto mide de área la base pues
necesitamos bueno como es un círculo el
área es pipo radio al cuadrado donde el
radio aquí vale 6 entonces 6 x 6 636 y
entonces tenemos 36 y muy bien pi por
radio al cuadrado y luego multiplicamos
por la altura que es 12 por 12 muy bien
entonces ya para ir concluyendo el
volumen de todo el cilindro y le pongo 2
porque son dos pedazos es igual a 12 por
36 por pi no quiero cometer un error
vamos a hacer esto 36 por 12 2 por 36
son 72 1 por 36 son 36 y sumamos 27 y 6
son 13 llevan 13 y 14 entonces tenemos
y muy bien pero hay que tener muchísimo
cuidado porque uno pensaría que ya
tenemos la respuesta y no es así esto es
el volumen y le puse aquí el 2
justamente por eso porque son dos
pedazos si yo quiero conocer el volumen
de sólo un pedazo hay que dividir a la
mitad y la mitad de 432 son 216 pi y
como nos preguntan nos dicen el volumen
se puede expresar como n p entonces hay
que dar quienes n pues aquí está n iv n
vale 216